il est l'un des 11 candidats déclarés à
la primaire de la droite Jacques Millard
député maire les républicains de maison
la fit était à Versailles jeudi soir
pour présenter son programme un
programme axé sur la souveraineté de la
France et la réorganisation de l'État
mon objectif c'est que la France
retrouve la souveraineté c'est que la
France soit maîtresse de ses destins que
vous soyez libre que la liberté
collective assure votre liberté et que
nous subissions pas les dictactes ni de
Bruxelles ni d'ailleurs le député maire
qui a sorti son manifeste pour la nation
tiré à 30000 exemplaires se positionne
dans la primaire comme Gauliste
souverainiste et compte donner un rang à
la France sur la scène internationale
malheureusement aujourd'hui la France a
disparu de la scène internationale en
Europe elle ne compte plus face à
l'Allemagne elle a fait des fautes
vis-à-vis de la Russie et au Proche et
au Moyen-Orient elle a complètement
disparu aussi et ce que je souhaite
c'est que mon mon pays revienne dans le
concert des nations pour dire ce qu'il a
à dire d'une manière libre souveraine et
déterminé pour le moment Jacques Millard
n'aurait pas encore acquis les
parrainages des 20 parlementaires
nécessaires pour accéder à la primaire
il mne un combat très courageux Jacques
m il sait très bien si vous voulez que
dans le cadre de ces primaires de la
droite je pense qu'il sait très bien
qu'il a pas beaucoup de chance mais il
le fait pour faire avancer les idées
qu'il développe c'est je pense un
candidat très intéressant au niveau de
ces idées
et un peu pour ma culture aussi pour
pour entretenir mais
mon choix aussi pour pour les primaires
si on entend les les programmes de
chacun ça nous permet de d'avoir un
meilleur choix au final pour au final
pour le parti à la fin en plus des 20
parlementaires Jacques Millard devra
récolter les parrainages de 250 élus et
2500 adhérents des parrainages qu'il
compte obtenir en multipliant ses
réunions à travers la France durant ses
prochains jours comme